fueron necesarias tres horas y media de
reunión antes de las primeras
declaraciones algún cogido de tono
hemos entendido el problema hay
evidentemente una sensación de fatiga
con relación a todos los aspectos de la
crisis sanitaria ha sido un momento que
hemos mantenido buenas conversaciones
para progresar sobre puntos concretos
también ha sido un momento de
explicaciones y es muy importante
explicar las dificultades del campo en
el que trabajamos cuando cavallo una
reunión con los sindicatos de profesores
que concluyó con una serie de anuncios
la primera claramente es la más
solicitada el suministro de 5 millones
de mascarillas ffp2 para todos los
profesionales que trabajan con alumnos
que no usan cubrebocas básicamente en la
educación infantil otra de las medidas
exigidas más personal el gobierno se ha
comprometido a contratar a 3 mil 300
personas para reemplazar a los
profesores que a menudo no dan abasto
finalmente las evaluaciones de primaria
previstas para la semana próxima quedan
aplazadas para los sindicatos estos
avances son un primer paso y se animó un
constante en los últimos meses hemos
constatado que ciertos anuncios
nacionales que pueden ser interesantes
no se traducen en todo el territorio en
realidad así que las cosas van en buen
camino pero estaremos atentos no ha sido
necesario llegar a una huelga unitaria
de todas las organizaciones sindicales
como la principal federación de padres y
madres de alumnos para que finalmente
empiecen a escuchar las reivindicaciones
que en algunos casos tenemos desde hace
un año y medio
entre otras cosas fueron los múltiples
cambios de protocolos sanitarios lo que
desencadenó la movilización masiva de
este jueves y en este ámbito el gobierno
tiene una línea roja en ningún caso se
cerrará una clase cuando se detecte un
primer caso de kobe 19